let's say you or your company built an
application
a while back and now you would like to
bring it up to snuff
and offer features that modern apps have
today
for example you may want to enable voice
ordering
or mobile payments or you may want to
make it easy for other developers to
integrate into your app
or maybe you would like to create a
unified experience across different
lines of business
and multiple backend services in this
episode
i will cover how google's api management
tool called apigee
helps organizations create digital
experiences for both
older backend services microservices
hybrid or multi-cloud environments and
fully serverless
stacks
api stands for application programming
interface
and it's like a library of functions
that passes information
over the web it defines the inputs and
outputs
available over http for example
let's say you are a logistics company
and you would like to enable your
partners to integrate your package
tracking service
into their ecommerce website you then
create an
api that takes shipment details as
inputs and returns a tracking id in the
response
another api uses the tracking id to
check the status of the package
this now makes your service portable you
can create
services not just for partners but for
your customers employees
vendors etc there are two developer
audiences that most benefit from an api
management tool
there are those that build and manage
apis known as the producers
and those that use the apis aka
consumers
now the challenge to the producer is to
design an easy to use api
keep developers abreast of changes and
ensure things do not break as
functionality evolves
they also have to consider three core
design components
such as how will i prevent unauthorized
access to keep things secure
how compatible will my services be when
working with other platforms and devices
and finally how can i measure
that things are running smoothly as you
can quickly see
that's a lot of layers to consider here
then there are consumers of apis who
need to easily discover
and find the apis they need and then
quickly understand
how to use them an api is really only
useful if it can easily be adopted by
other developers
so with these audiences in mind apogee
helps manage the entire lifecycle of an
api
let me discuss three key pillars the
first is it offers a supportive portal
for other developers to discover your
apis
rapidly understand them with the
intention that they can build
applications with them the second is
monitoring
and analytics these are available so
that your api program managers can see
which apis are used most and
how you can also receive alerts when
appropriate
the third is the api runtime which
executes the policies you configure for
security
traffic management and efficiency of
your apis
what is especially nice is that you can
make changes without disrupting users
because apogee is a proxy that isolates
the app developer
from your backend service for example
you can change your database
implementation
move your services to a new host or make
any other changes to the service
implementation
and by maintaining a consistent
front-end api
existing client apps will continue to
work regardless of how
changes occur in the back end you also
create
one or more api proxies that map
publicly available urls to your backend
services
a proxy is the http endpoint
on apigee that developers use to access
your backend services
you can optionally apply policies on a
proxy to also add
functionality to a service without
having to make any changes to the
actual backend service such as data
transformations
filtering conditional logic custom code
and many other actions the important
thing to remember
is that you implement policies on apogee
not on your backend server
next you bundle the api proxies and
publish them
in an api product next you let your
developers know that the api product is
available
and once app developers know about the
availability of your api product
they can register as an app developer
for your api product
create an app to obtain an api key for
that api product
and finally make requests to your
services passing the api key with each
request
and there you have it a quick
walkthrough on how apogee helps create
robust digital experiences by leveraging
apis
and having a tool set and portal to
manage them
if you would like to learn more this is
only episode 1 of a series of short
videos to help you get started
also in this video's description we have
several helpful links
and friends if you found this episode
helpful you can click like or subscribe
to the channel cheers